so this is a final
final update in the Adam Levine there's
a part three and and I gotta say there's
a part three for one reason only
so remember what I was telling you about
when we had the conversation towards the
end about
okay quick recap if you aren't aware
Adam Levine was out here apparently
messaging everybody in their DMS telling
them how hot and beautiful they are some
people feel like that's cheating me
parsley I just think he's being very
complimentary and positive shout outs to
Adam out here spreading that body
positivity hey [ __ ] you hot as [ __ ] who
doesn't feel better about their body
when they hear that from Adam okay good
man people alleged that he was cheating
one tick tocker alleges that Adam
apologizes now I came in with the take
that I don't think this man was cheating
for one simple reason his wife knows and
his wife is fine with it now this was
just me speculating but judging by how a
lot of Hollywood relationships work
that's what I believed now
update recently the wife who's a
Victoria's Secret model named uh Behati
prinslow okay CK bound said that she's
not bothered by what happened she's more
bothered by how it all came out and it
was embarrassing publicly that's exactly
what the [ __ ] you said that's what I was
saying that's exactly what you said
that's verbatim you said
I don't think they cheating because they
got a whatever some kind of
understanding it's really just that in
the press it looks bad that's what you
said yes and it is embarrassing have
friends because like even if she has
that understanding with that it's not
just your friends now everybody in your
your business because even though she
has an understanding with him when she's
like listen you go do your dirt just
don't bear the family having to explain
that our thing to most normal people is
is embarrassing because most people
don't get down get it okay she's a
Victoria's Secret model she's been
around a lot of these rich dudes her
whole life probably okay or her
professional life so she knows what it
is okay so when she's married one I'm
currently sure she's not under No
Illusion about what it's like they got
two kids together they're expecting a
third they're just trying to work
through it they got no issues what I'm
trying to relate to you guys is that a
lot of times when we see these cheating
scandals it is what Kevin Samuels used
to speak about it's a scandal for us
there you go whoa
a scandal for y'all
[Music]
we know we know how it works
you can't it's Scandal for like
man you you working go for it tell them
you work in hotels you see enough [ __ ]
that you're like all right it'd be like
that tell them we're not filmed but we
had to go up he here
and I worked in the hotel where where
people used to stay at what kind of
people
drivers
party's going on
I mean it'd be like you like oh hi your
wife your wife your wife is your wife is
coming tomorrow and and you I
room service yeah
[Laughter]
and and then you you wonder why they
make you sign
mbas and you're like oh oh room service
where should I put this
over there and it'd be like that I'm not
even joking okay not just any anybody
you want to know how not embarrass these
people want to be so there was a
congressman I think he's in a wheelchair
this white dude in the U.S he was on a
podcast all right and he was just
talking crazy he was talking about what
it's like to be now in uh Washington how
people invite him to like be swingers
with their wives how Congressmen have
these huge orgies and sex while and
rough this dude was in the next election
cycle got shafted so bad and ostracized
by the Republican party why do you think
that is not because what he said was not
true but because he wasn't supposed to
say that [ __ ] out loud there's a kind of
unspoken rule be it with
journalists or a lot of the people even
living in these kind of like adjacent
spheres to the political scene where
they don't report on a lot of this stuff
because everyone has an understanding
the heads of the newspapers have
understandings the people in power have
understandings it's like listen unless
something illegal is happening or it's
like a conflict of interest this should
we let it slide
you guys think that because you guys
don't hear about these scandals every
day or this cheating or infidelity or at
least like stepping out of marriages
that it's not no it's happening all the
time and everybody knows it's happening
in those worlds they just don't report
on it because there's an understanding
and the thing that happened is I
remember what happened with Bill Clinton
and when it happened I was younger but
then after that I worked in the industry
and stuff and I reflected on that and
I'm like
it wasn't about that I don't know why
they outed it out like that but who
cares
because stuff like that's been happening
so
why did it get out it
it's not because we think we we hold a
president at an affair [ __ ] you think
that John F
and all on him then
they were really they all do it it was
actually open that Maryland whatever hey
we're not going to go into that but so
that's why it made me think like why is
it out like that
why this is out like that and it made it
so much noise for that what's happening
well under there what are you trying to
do well there's a reason this is out
like that is because he was an idiot and
instead of going with a professional or
somebody who's industry vetted he went
this moon was in random people's DMS
shooting his shot you were involving for
me I'm talking about Clinton
oh well him it was at the workplace and
the woman had a lot to say yeah right
again that's that's the same thing you
can't it's same thing that's exactly
what you said there are ways you do it
to make sure everything's kosher but but
that's why remember when we had that
discussion with the whole freshman with
you guys and you're like we never paid
for box only losers pay for box and I'm
like you're an idiot yeah because if you
know anything about dudes who have or
ultra wealthy one thing they definitely
do is they pay for box or they pay for
prostitutes whatever because
if they don't want what's happening to
Adam Levine right the reason why some
athletes get outed every time they get
out of this cheaters you want to know
why it's because they're stepping out of
their marriage not with a professional
but with a regular ass person with
George Paul George
had his uh he decided to take place and
send it to some rain abroad and then
they got out and everyone everywhere out
there you haven't heard of people Paul
George but it's not because this dude's
not out here doing [ __ ] it's because
he's learned his lesson and now he has a
professional service I was talking about
in the last video how athletes all use a
professional provider to set them up
with women and they just toss the same
women around from guy to guy so bring it
all back basically and if your argument
is well these guys don't need to they
don't need to pay they don't need to pay
to get boxed no they don't
they pay for the other service
the hush service
don't grab your [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
and leave there you go yeah I don't have
to pay for box I'm paying for something
else so that's so that's how they do it
that's and and that's how they have to
do it or
or you go to Chris Brown route
where you get a bunch of women thrown
into a van they come by your place they
know where they're going it's not like
they're throwing like traffic okay I was
like where are you going Hey
listen they go up they show up to the
spot they sign ndas they have all their
Electronics confiscated and then it's
basically a Fest
yes now you might be wondering that's
disgusting why would I Hey listen have
you seen Chris Brown fans a lot of them
would jump by the chance obviously women
say they read their hand they'll accept
getting beaten up if it means he beat
that [ __ ] up you feel me so
I'm just saying
I just laughed because it was bars I
just I don't know that that was it's
another world
it's another world like I don't think
people so that's why when I hear folks
talk about people I would never how do
you mean it's not for you they would
you're not Prime in private jetsu I
would but I don't care about that I know
you don't care that's why it's not for
you that's why you weren't invited okay
it's another world that's what I'm
trying to tell y'all it is it is it's
crazy okay none of these people that you
think are faithful are faithful none of
them I used to believe that as well and
then I met the industry person who sets
up a lot of these dudes he's like this
client this I said [ __ ] who [ __ ] what
but I thought he loved Jesus he says yes
on weekdays I said oh [ __ ]
guess it's Satan on Sundays so
it's a different world sometimes I'm
trying to say that's all I'm trying to
say and that's why I'm saying it's none
of your business because it's not yeah
none yeah of your business because you
you y'all move differently and that's
okay it's all right as long as it's not
illegal but it's really that it's really
that and it is yeah someone wants to
start things and ruin you whatever we're
not they're gonna try to do it yeah yeah
it's like that whole Kevin Hart Scandal
happened and then everybody went oh I
can't believe it was like he cheated on
his first wife then cheat on the second
one but if you're honest you already
know he was doing a whole lot more the
entire time it's just that he had a
family friendly image and that needs to
be maintained so when he got messy it
caused a lot of problems that's it money
the people who get involved with these
athletes any celebrities and these
politicians know what it is they're
doing it for a quick check
um the athletes and all of them know
what it is and their wives know what it
is they either have a don't tell me I
don't want to see it policy or they're
like keep me in private but don't make
sure any any shame brings up that's it
it's an arrangement yeah and so that's
why whenever I hear people talk about
love and then they point to celebrities
like Beyonce and Jay-Z and all them uh
let me tell you if you think those
people are faithful you are [ __ ]
delusional
don't
don't hold any of these relationships
that you see in the Public's free on a
pedestal it's all fluff and images for
social media
that's all it is hey hey
I want that will and Jay to love
[ __ ] I hope you're ready to go bald
it's alopecia no [ __ ] you just bought
stop
[ __ ] out of here bro for years
for years yeah
is there anything you want to tell this
topic of uh cheating all this stuff no
no
Hey listen if you look long enough those
there's a lot yeah